for you uh Memphis has such a rich
history in hip-hop
how influenced Were You by Memphis
hip-hop growing up and if and if not
Memphis hip-hop what else like who else
were you influenced by just your style I
was influenced by um uh Boosie Birdman
Lil Wayne all the Lil Wayne rappers as a
rapper influenced you yeah Birdman boss
the boss man
show that boy for sure I
I
got that work by the Big Timers it was
one of my favorite albums of all time
yeah yeah and neither of those guys are
great at rapping yeah and I love I love
how Birdman like he he
pushed Wayne for sure
he might be the best CEO ever yeah like
it ain't just about to see your tip
though it's just like
you know what I'm saying like he just
like that type of soul in your corner
yeah but I don't got that right
everybody want to be like that person
everybody want to step on it Master P
yeah I was born on Master P you were
listening
uh I was I was born May Crack like this
yeah Hey listen I stole the No Limit
chain I mean I'm older than you so I was
like you you were born like
1996. you were born when Master P was
lit when the ice cream man came out yeah
this I was born on him you know what I'm
saying so yeah I go to sleep I got they
put a pill my mom used to put a pillow
under my uh I mean a speaker under my
pillow playing Master P playing Master P
that song
that's how I go to sleep that's amazing
it's a mystical just screaming in your
ear yeah with the dreads yeah man he's
so crazy hot boy is my favorite movie I
just talked to Silk before um I flew her
Hot Boys is your favorite movie yeah in
life yeah hmm how many movies have you
seen a million of them and Hot Boys
starring silk the Shockers your face hi
boys like Silk man silk just got through
talking so no limit so like I always say
that Silk is the best worst rapper ever
the worst rapper no the best the best
worst rapper ever I must give on it
cause he ain't gonna lose me so you see
that movie poster over there belly that
is the best worst movie ever
why is it worse because it's really not
a good movie but it's great
I love that [__] movie that movie is
nostalgic that movie like reminds me of
a place in my childhood it's amazing I
wish Hype Williams would have kept
making movies
okay what about Richard that's right
it's not belly I like belly but Bailey's
the best worst movie ever
okay and silk the Shocker is the best
worst rapper ever okay what about
Shadows shot is a classic I sold so many
of those at the Swap Meet [__] that's
how I got my name bootleg Kev I was at
the Swap Meet [__] burning so it shot
us I was a shot of when they first came
up shot this is a [__] classic yeah
awesome I know everything about it kill
a season camera and that [__] was great
if we're talking about just like Cameron
he was he was a d he was my favorite
Master P movie was I got the hookup
though
that [__] was great yes that was way
better I stay watching it way better
than hot boys
the guy who was in the movie what's his
name the comedian who played Isaiah on
Friday he died blue you took my um
they used to call them blue yeah a
little dude yeah yeah I got the hookup
was so funny oh yeah oh he I was like I
had to do walked into the truck
on me I had Masterpiece shoes bro
shoes nobody did except me in my school
them shits was ugly why are you wearing
them because I love [__] Master P I
stole a No Limit chain bro I had that
[__] ghetto dope I had the [__]
was it trying real of course not it was
like [__] silver I thought it was
like 15 why are you stealing
you wanted a bad child and I wanted to
feel like I was in no limit I fee you
know I feel I had that I had the Wu-Tang
chain
yeah okay but you got the you know
you're CMG I used to walk around
um thinking out with Lil Wayne and I was
a little I had to have a shirt around my
head that's funny with like looking
forward to my mouth and [__]
Zone you say you you love boozy he just
got me yeah he is one of the guys in rap
that if you meet him he'll never
disappoint you because you'll meet some
of your like heroes or the people you
look up to when you meet him you're like
ah he was kind of a dick or he was he
wasn't who I thought he'd be you mean
Boosie and he's like
this is you're as advertised yeah we we
acting like the you guys act alike for
sure
that could be a good a good and bad
thing because Boosie's wild no he wild
but he like
like he streaked though of course he is
Street wow and he's and he's very he's a
smart dude yeah yeah he knows right
wrong he knows how to get to the bag for
sure he'll Hustler he'll get it he goes
to a city whatever he can sell anything
oh yeah
sell anything whatever bag you got he'll
take it he's gonna say he's gonna sell
it to you whatever it is he don't matter
he gonna get some money